it was the defining message from his
first party conference speech
this conservative government will always
balance the books if instead
we argue there is no limit on what we
can spend
what is the point in us but today the
head of the international monetary fund
has a clear message for rishi sunak now
is not yet the time to balance the books
of course now is a good time to think
about
balancing the books down the road but
it is more important to make sure that
firms and workers are supported
while we are still wrestling with the
pandemic
it comes as the chancellor faces
criticism for introducing a job support
scheme which is considerably less
generous than the one that accompanied
the first wave of the pandemic
that matters because the imf is seen as
the world's fiscal watchdog
it's holding its annual conference
virtually this week but throughout
one theme has come across loud and clear
the imf's annual meetings have been
dominated by one
topic covert 19 and the impact on
government balance sheets i'll give you
a sense of what we're talking about here
this
shows you total national debt for
advanced economies going all the way
back to the victorian period and you can
see where it rose
during each of the world wars we'll have
a look at what happens to this line
in the age of covet 19. it goes even
higher up to
124.7 of gdp actually if we draw a line
going all the way back you can see
that is the highest on record even so
the imf thinks we could borrow even more
but debt is not the only issue on the
economic agenda
once again it's hard to ignore the noise
coming from the brexit negotiations
but while downing street says the trade
talks are over the managing director
believes there's still time
these are the last weeks of negotiations
and always important
to focus on the outcome but even more so
now
and the two sides need to aim for the
best possible outcome
for their countries and their people
clock is ticking
but it is not yet midnight
still it is that warning about not yet
balancing the books that will attract
the most attention
as the covert restrictions intensify the
chancellor's economic support and its
generosity
remains under scrutiny ed conway sky
news